Trude minutes long so Kristen who knows  that was knitted yeah I bet I'm doing  this I'm so good at this  hey guys this is me Hey so how do you  know that your words are fun every  moment is a blessing from God I just  like it because I mean wow no I'm really  good I went to three months of baby's  father did you really hey do you know  that Deena George over two months beauty  school three months why would he you're  recording things you're doing a live  Google hangout right not it's just why  not okay because this is clearly the  greatest thing for you right now this is  the best decision you've ever had here  okay good what's your name George - good  at veils